as medical professionals struggle to
treat thousands of coronavirus patients
Donald Trump has repeatedly and
inaccurately assured the public that
vast amounts of vital supplies are
readily available or will be provided
soon we have tremendous numbers of
ventilators into the masks and numbers
of Basques are incredible but the
promised supplies aren't getting to many
people who need them one Indiana
Hospital begged anyone with a sewing
machine to start making masks makes you
feel less helpless and it empowers you
an Heiser Bush the world's largest beer
maker is making medical grade hand
sanitizer as is the much smaller Alabama
craft distillery yellowhammer
the processes are pretty similar to what
we were doing before so it wasn't a
difficult swap
the global Hanes brand makes underwear
and sports clothing now under contract
with the government it's also making
masks we're a really big cotton apparel
manufacturer anywhere from socks and
underwear the t-shirts and sweatshirts
so we can we can really crank out the
goods when we need to so we expect to
make between 50 million and 75 million
mass for the federal government with
assembly lines shut down the Ford Motor
Company is collaborating with other big
manufacturers General Electric and 3m to
produce medical face shields using 3d
printers the companies also hope to
adapt auto air filters and other
equipment to make critically needed
ventilators and respirators last weekend
president Trump falsely said the
companies were making respirators right
now
in fact full-scale production is months
away efforts by companies large and
small will greatly help in the crisis
but all those efforts take time and as
the pandemic spreads rapidly time is one
thing doctors nurses and patients
haven't got rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles
kimly halket joins us now live from
washington d.c Kimberly as we're seeing
these numbers escalate I believe we're
also expecting some new statistical
modeling from the White House today is
there an emerging sense there of the
scale of the spread across the country
now yeah according to dr. deborah birx
who is one of the top public health
officials coordinating this for the
coronavirus task force on monday she
told reporters Tuesday expect some
pretty grim numbers in terms of where
this is headed particularly in the next
two weeks this is the data that she's
going to share with the public that the
governors across the United States have
been using to essentially tell their
residents to stay home we have roughly
two-thirds of the United States
population about 250 million people
staying at home as a result of this
modeling and the numbers we understand
we expect to hear are not going to be
good already you mentioned that there
are almost 165 in thousand in infections
in the United States and what we expect
that this is only going to get higher in
the next two weeks what we're hearing is
there could be at least 100 to 200,000
deaths in the United States and that's
if the social distancing that is in
place right now stays that way in terms
of people following it perfectly so this
doesn't paint a very good picture so
this is what we're waiting to hear from
from the White House in the midst of all
of this of course we still have the
worst outbreaks in the United States
centered around New York City but we see
some big hot spots starting to pop up
Louisiana Illinois Michigan we're
preparing here in the United States for
some grim weeks ahead
Kimberly hell cut there for us in
Washington DC thanks very much Kimberly